Hello, everybody.
My name is Ryan Johnson and I'm
a data science advisor here,
At Posit.
And welcome to this month's
Enterprise Community meetup,
where we'll discuss
an end to end data
science workflow
using Posit team.
As a reminder, this will
be a recurring event
on the last Wednesday
of every month,
and we hope it'll
serve as a good primer
for those new to Posit
team, but also helps
current Posit team users become
more familiar with our tools.
Now, every month we will
cover a different topic
and highlight all three
tools within Posit Team.
We have Posit Workbench,
Posit Connect and Posit Package
Manager.
So during and after
each presentation
there will be a few members
of the Posit team in the chat,
to address any questions
you have about our tools,
workflows, licensing
and anything else
you may be curious about.
So this month we have a pretty
exciting topic for everyone,
especially those within the
life sciences, healthcare
and pharmaceutical space.
So we are going
to use Posit Team
to create a Shiny application
of clinical trial data
in our all while discussing
best practices for working
within what's known as
a validated environment.
Now, as we go through
today's session,
I'll be sure to stop and note
various ways Posit team can
help support a validated
compute environment
and encourage good
coding practices.
So let's get started.
Now I first want to make
sure everyone on the call
has a solid, high level
understanding of Posit Team.
So starting off here
at the very top,
we have our data
scientist and analyst.
These are the folks writing
code and creating insights
using Posit Workbench, and they
can use whatever language they
want, including R or python,
as well as any development
environment they choose,
including the RStudio IDEl
Jupyter lab, Jupyter
Notebooks and VS Code.
Now for the R developers they
may be creating insights
like Shiny applications.
Pins RMarkdown documents or
APIs using the Plumber package.
And for Python developers,
they have a home
to create interactive
applications using things
like streamlit, dash, bokeh, Shiny.
They can also create documents
using Jupyter Notebooks or even
Quarto and APIs using
Flask and Fast API.
Now, once the developers
create content,
they need a way to share it with
the people that need to see,
including decision makers,
coworkers, clients, or maybe
even just friends and family.
And so that's the
role of Posit Connect,
which is our professional
publishing platform.
And finally, we have
Posit Package Manager,
which helps organize
and centralize
the great open source R and
Python packages your team uses
as well as host and distribute
any internally developed R
and Python packages
you've created.
So for today's
session, we are going
to start within
Posit Workbench
and we will leverage
the RStudio IDE
to create a Shiny application
in R using clinical trial data.
And then we'll publish this
application to Posit Connect
all within the context of
a validated environment.
Now just for awareness,
the clinical trial data
that we'll use today
is publicly available.
It's been properly
de-identified and cleansed
for demonstration purposes.
So before we actually
dive into this workflow,
let's take a few moments
just to talk more
about this clinical
trial data set.
Now, what is it?
Where does it come from.
Now as a high level
overview, clinical trials,
they are conducted usually
to assess the efficacy
of some disease intervention.
So during the trial, data
will be collected, organized
and eventually that data
will find itself inside
of an analysis ready data set
called an ADaM or analysis data
model data set.
So these atom data
sets are usually
what's submitted to various
regulatory agencies,
such as the Food and Drug
Administration, or FDA.
So here's actually
a quick glimpse
into what this example
ADaM data set looks like.
Now, we are only going
to focus on the columns
that you see here,
which include things
like subject, ID number, the
treatment group, age, BMI,
height, weight and
years of education.
So these subject level
variables are usually
found within a specific
type of ADaM data,
so-called a subject
level or ADSL data set.
Now while this data is not
particularly large, it does.
Contain numerous
descriptive columns.
And it can be a
challenge to create
static insights such as plots
and tables to explore them all.
So for this reason, we will
create an interactive web
application using the
Shiny R package, which
I'm showing here.
So this application
will allow viewers
to explore the
data for themselves
and compare various
subject level
variables between
the three treatments
groups, which we'll talk about
a little bit more in a bit.
So to start, let's
open in RStudio session
within Posit Workbench.
So here we have in
Posit Workbench.
On the right hand side.
You can see some of the
projects I've been working on.
But we'll go ahead
and click New session.
And you can see
right off the bat
that I have a choice between
Jupyter Notebooks, Jupyter
Lab, RStudio Pro and VS Code.
So for today, we're
going to select RStudio.
Now, before I
start this session,
I want to briefly describe our
demo computing environment here
at Posit.
So we host Posit Workbench
within a clustered environment
which is managed by a
tool called Kubernetes,
which you can see here.
So for validated
compute environments,
it's often necessary that
certain aspects of this RStudio
session are controlled for
including what R version is
being used, which R or system
packages come preinstalled.
And so that's where tools
like Docker come into play.
And here at the
very bottom, you can
see that I have a choice
for various Docker images
I can deploy within, and
this can be customized
to your team's needs.
So for this demo, I'm just going
to stick with the default image
right here and we'll go ahead
and click Start session.
So while this is booting up,
before we do any analysis,
it's really important that
we establish a new RStudio
project for this
clinical trial analysis.
So this will provide us
with a working directory
for this project and
only this project.
So this helps ensure that
the analysis we do here
that they won't impact
anything else on our system
or another project.
And this is generally
considered good practice
for not just clinical
trial data, but really
all data science projects.
So to create a project, we
have a few different options.
We can go to File at
the top of my screen
and select New Project.
There's also a button right
underneath the Edit button
down here.
Or if you go to the right
hand side of your screen,
you can see project none.
And this is actually a good
way of knowing that I'm not
currently within a project.
So let's go ahead
and create one.
I'm going to click on this
button and select New Project.
So this is going to be
a brand new project.
So we're going to go ahead
and create a new directory.
But I do have a choice to create
a project within an existing
directory or pull on a
project from version control.
But we'll stick with new
directory, select New project,
the first option and
the directory name.
I'll just say test_ADSL_analysis.
I'll place
This directory as a project within
under my Posit project's
directory.
And then you'll see two
boxes right here, create,
Git repository and use
renv with this project.
So I'm going to
check those boxes
and I'm going to
hit Create project.
So while this is booting up, a
quick note on those two boxes
that we just checked.
So to ensure reproducibility
for your project,
it's always a good idea
to use version control
and to initialize the
project with something
known as renv.
Now, once we finish
our workflow today,
we'll actually go back
and discuss renv
in more detail and how it can
be used to record our project's
package environment.
All right, so here we are
now within our new project,
and you can see the name of
it in the top right corner.
So first step in our
workflow is to upload
that ADaM ADSL
dataset, which
can be found right here on the
see this website or the GitHub
page.
So this is going to be the data
set right here at adsl.xpt.
So I've downloaded this
file to my local machine
and to upload it
to Posit Workbench.
All we have to do is select
this upload button, Choose File
and I'll select adsl.xpt,
hit Open and OK.
And now we can see
the file right here,
the bottom in our
files directory.
So now we have the data
in our environment.
We need to install some
packages, some R packages that
will be used for the creation
of our Shiny application.
Now, in a validated
environment, developers
are often limited to a
select number of packages
that their team has approved
for clinical data analysis.
So the question
really becomes, how
do I make sure I use packages
from a validated repository?
Well, enter Posit
Package Manager.
So here in our demo environment
of Posit Package mMnager,
you can see I have a few
customized repositories
over here on the left
hand side of your screen,
including right down here a
validated repository which
includes packages that
we have classified
as validated for clinical work.
Now this is just an
example repository
to demonstrate that it's
possible to create customized
repositories depending
on your team's needs.
All right.
So we can start exploring
these various packages,
but how do we
actually install them
from this repository
into RStudio
session and Posit Workbench?
So to do this, we're
going to select the Setup
tab at the top of
your screen, and I'm
going to scroll down to
the bottom right here.
And we see using packages
inside the RStudio IDE
and you have the choice.
You can change the repository
URL using the global options
or you can set it
more programmatically
by running the code
right here at the very bottom.
So I'm going to copy
this code and I'm
going to come back
into Posit Workbench
and I'm going to paste it
into my R profile script
that you see right here.
So when I click
on this and we're
going to add a few
new lines here,
I wrote a comment to myself
saying validated repo
and I'm going to paste that
URL that I just copied,
which you can see here is
that validated repository
on Posit Package Manager.
So the .R profile
script will always
be run as soon as you
start a new R session.
So I'm going to go
ahead and save this file
and I'm going to restart R
by clicking session restart.
R. so if I close
at this .R profile
and coming to my console, I
can check my active repository
by running options
repos and hit Enter.
And you can see that I have
my validated rePository
ready to be used.
And to install packages from.
All right, so once we have
all that we can, well for our
Shiny application,
we actually need
to install some of
the packages first.
So before I actually bring
in the Shiny application,
let's first install
some packages.
So I've actually copied these
install script over here
and I'm just going to
paste it into my console
and we have a few packages
here that we're going to.
So we're going to install
the Shiny package, obviously
to create our Shiny application.
The haven package is going to
be used to read in this adsl.xpt
data
set, bslib
is used to customize the
user interface for our Shiny
application and then ggplot2
scales and plotly.
These will all be used to
create that box plot for our Shiny
application.
So I'll go ahead and I'm
going to hit Enter and install
all these packages from
that validated repository.
All right.
There we go.
So now the stage is set.
So let's go ahead and
create a Shiny application
to explore this ADaM data set.
So to do this, I'm first going
to create a blank script.
So right here in
the top left corner,
I have this little
dropdown menu and I'm
going to select R
script and I'm just
going to paste the code
for the Shiny application.
We're not going to dive too
much into the contents of it.
But I do want to demonstrate
it's functionality.
So before we do that,
let's first save it.
So I hit this
little floppy symbol
and we'll save it as app.R
And you can
see right here, I
can run this application
within the RStudio IDE
running on Posit Workbench.
So select Run app, and I'll open
up my viewer pane down here.
And so this is the
Simple application
that explores the subject
level variables in this study,
and it compares them between
the various treatment arms.
So here we have those
that were given a placebo.
In the middle, we
have those that
were given a low dose of a
drug known as Xanomeline,
and then another treatment
group that was given
a high dose of Xanomeline.
And on the y axis, we had the
various subject level variables
that we can explore,
such as age, baseline
BMI, baseline height,
baseline weight.
And we have years of education.
So now that we've built
the Shiny application
within our validated
environment,
it's now time to publish
it, to Posit Connect,
so that we can easily share
it with the people that
need to see it.
So for instructions on how to
publish a Shiny application
from within the
RStudio IDE, I'm
actually going to
enlist the help of one
of our jumpstart examples on
the Posit Connect home page.
So let me switch over to Posit
Connect in our home page.
Here I can select, publish and
I can go to jump start examples.
And you can see right here I
have a portfolio dashboard,
Shiny application.
So we're not actually going
to use this specific app
within this example, but we
will use the instructions
for how to publish to
Posit Connect, which
starts on step five.
So we'll start to get started
using portfolio dashboard
and then I'll skip forward to
step five, which is publish.
So it tells us that
we need to push
the publish button,
this little blue button
from within the RStudio IDE.
And if publishing for
the very first time,
you'll actually
need to grab the URL
for your Posit
Connect server.
So I'll just copy that to
have it on my clipboard.
All right.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So we'll come back to Posit
Workbench, where I have
my Shiny application running.
Go ahead and stop it.
And here's our Shiny application.
This app.R script.
And right at the top, we see
that blue publishing button.
So I'll go ahead
and click on this.
And you can see I'm publishing
this for the very first time,
so I'll select Next.
Now I'm going to publish,
To Posit Connect,
and here's where
you want to paste
in the address for your
connect server, which
you can see for us it's
actually auto populated.
So I'll select Next.
And it's going to get this
little pop up menu right here
to connect.
And I see what I want to do.
So select Connect
successfully activated token
so I can close out of this
and connect my account.
And now you can see the Posit
connect instance over here
in the top right quadrant.
We can give our application, our
Shiny application a title.
I'll just leave it as
a default right here.
And this is where
you want to choose
what's going to go into
the deployment bundle.
And so really we only need
this ADSL data set as well as
the code for the
Shiny application,
which is showing over here
and then we'll hit Publish.
And so once we do this,
we'll get this deploy tab
that opens up and RStudio pretty
much takes care of this for us.
So what it's doing
right now, it's
actually capturing
my environment.
So it's looking to see what
R version am I using,
what packages am I using, what
versions of those packages
and some other information
about my environment and then
replicates it on the Posit
Connect server, which it just
opened up to.
And once that environment's
been replicated,
it then deploys my
Shiny application,
which we see right here.
All right, so here's the
running Shiny application.
I can still interact
with it just like it was
running within Posit Workbench.
And now, but it's
hosted on Posit Connect.
And again, the main
purpose of Posit connect
is making it super easy to
share this content with people
that need to see it.
So here within the Access tab.
So as a publisher, I have
control over who has access.
I can change the
sharing settings.
Currently it's set to
specific users or groups,
and I'm the only one
that's me and the only one
that can actually view
or edit this application.
Now, if I want to
be very specific,
I can maybe share
this with Rachael.
And now we would be the only
two that can view this content.
I have a few other
options as well.
I can select all
users log in required
and that just means that if
someone has the credentials
to log into the
Posit Connect server,
they can view this
content or I can select
anyone no loggin required.
And that basically
means that if someone
has the URL at the top
of my screen, which
you can customize
down here, they
can then view this content.
So it pretty much opens it up
to the world and the people that
are seeing it, they don't have
to know anything about Shiny
R, Connect.
They can just view it like
they would any other website.
Ok so to wrap things
up, let's actually
go back to Posit
Workbench and we're just
going to take a moment to
record our R environment.
So that anyone
else or probably more likely
our future self could
reproduce our work.
So some of the things will
want to record,
include, you know, which
R version that I use,
which R packages we use and
what versions of those packages
as well as which repositories
we use to install the packages.
Now, as I mentioned
earlier, we're.
Going to use an R package
called renv to help out here.
So renv, it's an open
source R package and it's name
is shorthand for
reproducible environments.
So we're going to use renv
to record our environment
into what's known as an
renv.lock file, which
you can see right here.
I'll go ahead and click on this.
So this is the current
state of our lock file, which
was created when we first
initialize this RStudio project
and we can read it
from top to bottom.
You can see we're using R for
this project version 4.2.
And here are the
active repositories.
When I first initialize
this project,
which we'll obviously
need to update
to reflect our
validator repository,
now everything below this
starting on line 11 right here.
This is information about
the packages in this project,
including which version I need.
Now, as you can see, we are
only seeing one package here.
The renv package.
And so we'll need to
update this lock file
to reflect the current state
of our package environment.
So to do this, I'm going to
open up my console down here,
clear my screen, and I'm going
to run from the renv package,
the snapshot function.
Well, let's ignore that
message for right now,
and we're going to see
some text right here.
So I think this is one
of my favorite parts
about the renv package, is that
it will actually inform us
what will happen if
we decide to proceed.
So it's letting us know that
all these packages that are not
currently in our lock file as
represented by this asterisk,
will be written to the lock
file with the version reflecting
reflected in my
current R environment.
So if this all
looks good to you,
which looks pretty good to
me, do you want to proceed?
I'll hit Y for
Yes and hit Enter.
And so now if we
open up a lock file,
you can see there is a
lot more packages in here,
but I didn't have to
edit this myself at all.
And it is now reflecting my
current R environment
And all those packages inside
and the correct versions.
And so this file can be
shared with other users,
or as a companion file for
FDA submission, for example.
It can be used to reproduce,
your R environment
and your analysis results.
And so with that, we
have come to the end
of our workflow for today.
So I hope everyone found
this month's demo helpful,
and we'd certainly love to chat
more about how Posit team can
assist with your data
science workflows
and support a validated
compute environment.
So feel free to stick
around and we'll
have a few Posit folks
available to answer
any questions you have.
So Thanks, everyone,
for joining and we
look forward to seeing
everyone again next month.
Thank you so much
for the demo, Ryan,
and Thank you, everybody,
for joining us today.
I see there's already
been a few great questions
in the chat.
And as Ryan mentioned, a
few of us from Posit
are going to stick around
here for another 15 minutes
and answer additional questions.
As a reminder, if you do want
to ask anything anonymously,
you can use the Slido link,
which we'll share in the chat
again.
But it's
pos.it/demo-questions
and I'll keep that open
for the rest of the week
if you want to add
anything there.
And we'll add the answers
to the questions there too.
While we are answering questions
using only the chat today,
if you'd like to talk with us
live, we can set that up too.
It's a little bit weird
hopping from one platform
to another in one
session, but I'm
going to share a
link in the chat
right now where
you could sign up
to go through any follow
up questions with Ryan
and I live too.
With that.
Thank you again for
joining us today.
We're going to go jump over
to the chat for Q and A, bye everybody.